[Applause]
you're telling me that the king of a
third-world country runs around and a
bulletproof cat soon why don't you ask
him yourself because he's right outside
because my king lives
[Music]
it was coming
Rashmi knew my hope you ready bro I'm
just getting started some fun
showoff
[Music]
all of the weapons secrets
it's all mine now
is this your king
this ends today
[Applause]
to get tickets now
hey everybody is Charlie let's break
down this new black panther so we get so
much more technology a little bit more
of the story and some of Michael B
Jordans kill monger actually speaking I
hope you're ready bro there's also a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so if you're wondering like why he
doesn't speak with the wakandan accent
or he doesn't speak like Black Panther
does it's because he grew up in exile in
the United States so if you remember the
Punisher how that's a very military
driven series the characters came up in
Afghanistan and a lot of the Middle
Eastern conflicts that's the same way
that kill monger came up so because this
is all set in present-day I'm wondering
if the Punisher would know who kill
monger is like they definitely weren't
from the same outfit but if kill monger
walked out of the US military with the
same kind of reputation is people like
the Punisher or even jigsaw then even if
they weren't from the same branch of the
military they would have heard about
each other like soldiers at the top
level even black ops soldiers would be
aware of what other people are doing
even though they might not know exactly
what kind of operations they were
involved in the way they're explaining
the kill monger named in the movie is
that he got that through his time in the
military so it gives you an idea for how
bloodthirsty he is so that's why his
skills are on par with Black Panthers
although if you've read the comics then
you know black panther actually studies
martial arts from all over the world as
well as Kunlun that's right he was
trained by the same monks that trained
Iron Fist but you have to imagine it's
like Iron Man if he trained in con LUN
like imagine Iron Man was that good at
hand-to-hand combat because black
panther's technology is on par with
stark tech if not better but speaking of
technology there's that extra scene with
Sheree where she sort of mocks him oh my
king stop it so they have this really
funny brother-sister relationship
whereby even though she's sort of like
the star of the group her special lab
there has that crystal lattice of
vibranium behind her that's what that
sculpture is meant to emulate but if you
see the window behind them it's just the
vibranium mines so obviously vibranium
is so central to their way of life
that's why you see so much of it in the
trailer this location it's just called
the great mound but this is the top of
you see here inside this is her lab
which is also inside of it
but I love the metaphor about how their
power is so central to the conflict in
this and that's why they visually keep
going back to this because vibranium is
their not-so-secret weapons so naturally
they're fighting over the weapons to
take over the world they're really
fighting over the vibranium in the rule
of Wakanda which gives you access to the
vibranium if you're confused about that
kill monger dialog where he talks about
taking everything from him your power
your wealth your nation and then they
flash to what looks like the sole world
where he looks like he's getting ready
to commune with the Panther God or some
sort of spiritual experience if this is
not the Dajjal eeeh which is sort of
like their area between life and death
where they can talk to the spirits of
the people that have died like he could
talk to his father in this place the
whole idea is that he was banished but
there is a theory that he could be a
royal bastard and that's why he has such
a strong claim and why it's so easy for
these other tribes to back him there are
a couple of the other big tribes in
Wakanda that don't see eye to eye with
Black Panther I've talked a little bit
about in Bacchus jabari tribe they've
sworn off all use of technology and
vibranium like they're purists they want
to live the way that their ancestors
lived before the great mound crashed to
Wakanda but I'm not totally sure that
that's these blue soldiers here from
this other tribe they could belong to
this person in green here he's one of
the leaders of the other biggest tribes
in Wakanda so just remember that even
though Black Panther is king of Wakanda
it's made up of a bunch of really big
tribes and if the tribal leaders don't
agree with them they could band together
and kick him off the throne which it
looks like he'll monger is trying to
incite them to do so this is big arc
with mbaku
I did a character breakdown for him
where it talks about how he's not
totally sure how he feels about Black
Panther but you see them in the infinity
war trailer standing next to each other
United so it gives you an idea for his
arc during the movie so it sounds like
everybody that hates Black Panther in
these moments here will stop hating him
but you still have to have a normal
villain and that's where ulysses klaw
comes in like he is the legit big bad of
the film even though kill monger seems
so powerful and threatening it actually
makes you wonder if kill monger is so
hell-bent on taking over Wakanda when
Black Panther inevitably takes him down
is it going to be another repeat of
Baron Zemo at the end of Captain America
Civil War because Zemo was responsible
for killing his father
I'm sorry about your father he seemed a
good man with a dutiful son
engines consumed you but without
forgiving him he spares his life and
puts him back in prison so with the
whole idea of the movie is Wakanda
forever they're chanting that during the
infinity war trailer so they need to
stop biting each other and form a united
front and kill monger is of Wakanda his
black panther are going to try and
rehabilitate him Winter Soldier style
like will he turn into his Winter
Soldier or is it going to be something
different but I think what we're all
really waiting to see is is that they're
tying infinity gem into this and how
they weave in the mysticism of the Black
Panther comics like how are they gonna
deal with the idea of the Panther God in
the fact that Black Panther can commune
with the people that have been Black
Panther before his ancestors like how
they can handle the Necropolis like the
really weird stuff that actually seems
like it's gonna be pretty cool but let
me know in the comments what are you
most hyped up about seeing in the black
panther film and if you weren't excited
about the film itself Kendrick is
actually doing an original album just
for the film that's right he's writing a
whole bunch of new original music for
Black Panther so it's gonna have a
sick-ass soundtrack I hope that they do
the same thing for infinity war like
that's like a whole other thing because
that'll be Marvel Studios 10th
anniversary so we'll probably see more
from that as we get closer to Black
Panther I don't know about a Super Bowl
trailer but just leave all your bonus
video requests in the comments below
there's a whole bunch of other Marvel
stuff happening besides Black Panther
and infinity war so if there's anything
that I haven't done a video about yet
just let me know in the comments like I
said there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I'll name a
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video but congratulations to the winner
from the last video Alvin please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
Thor's new weapon during infinity war
and you can click here for brand new
flash and learn about the Batman movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]